each year Microsoft Research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
good morning everybody it's my pleasure
this morning to introduce a good friend
to the hip research group here at
Microsoft Research Susan sim from the
University of California at Irvine like
us she's very interested in sort of
human aspects of the software
development process and she tells me
that she has a very sort of
non-traditional format talk for us this
morning so I'm I'm very intrigued and
anxious to see it so welcome Susan
thanks Rob for the introduction so I'm
going to be talking about some work that
I've been doing more thinking than work
it's heavily influenced by Science and
Technology studies as I looked back on
the research that I've been doing for
the last 10 years I was looking I've
been looking at you know psychological
factors in software development I've
been looking at social factors in
software development and any time I look
at social factors there's the psychology
or the organization and when I looked at
the cycle or associate the social
factors or the cycle if there's always
something missing from the picture and
as I brought more and more stuff in it
would got more and more complicated and
this is i also got into science and
technology studies because it seemed to
provide a way of dealing with more stuff
or more factors also on for my PhD
thesis I worked on benchmarking which is
an evaluation method for software tools
but also into in order to interpret my
results I used Thomas Kuhns theory of
scientific revolutions about scientific
paradigms and things like that so I
already got my toes wet into Science and
Technology studies so science and
technology studies what it tends to do
is look at let's see so you can
wickedness up the computer's gone to
sleep so science the technology studies
is kind of like you know you take the or
their psychology you take your sociology
or your social factors and you place it
within the context of a culture and you
also place that culture in the context
of history and it's the idea that people
are essentially the same over time the
trappings might change the clothes that
we wear might change the devices that we
use and all of the technology might
change but we're essentially the same
and so it has that basic idea and it's
really good at asking broad sweeping
questions about what is the nature of
things what are the interactions it's
not so good at answering questions so
I've been thinking about the question of
what does it mean to program a computer
because this is at the heart of a lot
this is kind of like the kind of
question that STS asks but also I think
this is the kind of question the kind of
what if question or the fundamental
question that you can ask that will lead
you down alternative paths or lead you
down other pathways in building software
yo you you try and identify with the
requirements are in the beginning but
when you're working with a customer you
lay off the customers often have a
difficulty expressing what their
requirements are because they're too
entrenched in their own environment to
see outside also they don't know what
the capabilities of the technology are
so you need somebody who is a
technologist or a requirements engineer
sophmore developer or somebody like that
to go in and you do a little bit of
psychotherapy and say what is it that
you really want to achieve here they
call this you know paving the cow path
sometimes customers just ask you to
automate what it is that they've already
done instead of build me a better way
and so by asking this kind of question
then we can figure out whether we are
paving the cow path when it comes to
software tools or is there another way
is there another way to do what it is
that we want to do so the question I'm
starting out with is what does it mean
to program a computer and we all have an
intuitive sense of what this is because
you know you can
if I told you you know is this person
technical or is that person technical or
not you have a pretty you can tell me
pretty quickly whether someone is a real
programmer or not so a systems
programmer is a real programmer a visual
basic programmers are not real
programmers or say a GUI programmer may
not be a real programmer so we have
these intuitive ideas about what is real
programming or what is not programming
so what does it mean to program a
computer so the title of this talk
deliberately riffs on Donald Knuth the
art of computer programming and this is
a pretty hardcore idea of what it means
to program a computer so you know this
is the second edition has three volumes
in it of a planned 782 volumes he's
working on the fourth volume right now
and he has to keep releasing subsections
of it because it's getting to be too big
and there he's talking about you know
turning that into to actual volumes he
may not finish this before he dies but
in general a computer scientists Revere
this work they think this is a huge
achievement is it's a pinnacle in terms
of intellectual work firstly it's got
analysis of algorithms running time
efficiency and he's trying to
comprehensively cover all of the
algorithms that we know and it's not
even written in a high-level language
it's the code the code examples that he
gives you are in machine language so
that you will have a basis for comparing
the complexity and time costs of each of
these algorithms so so this is a
particular view of what programming is
it's very mathematical very algebraic
that this is this is what it is that in
that you know the pinnacle or the the
kind of achievement this represents is
is is like more like math than it is
like human factors it's you if somebody
sitting in front of a computer and
during the codes instructing the
computer telling the computer what to do
these are the steps execute this and and
if you do it right or we're going to be
okay I should mention that this is work
in progress this is the first time I've
given this talk and I mean I don't
really know how to publish this work so
if you have any comments for me feel
free to stop and ask ask me questions or
or you know talk to me afterwards and
say oh this is what you can do with it
okay so what is the image of the
programmer that comes out when you hold
this up as a model or a Paragon for
programming well it looks like this okay
it's a stick figure genderless no
clothes I mean not that he's naked or
she is that the clothes don't matter you
know they're there the gender doesn't
matter that all of the social trappings
don't matter there's the chair and
there's the computer and the person
sitting in front of it that's it what's
the most important thing the noggin that
is driving the fingers to type things
into the computer this comic is taken
from website called XKCD does anyone
read this yes okay so uber geek very
very geeky but I just laughed so much I
guess it just shows how much of a geek i
am most of the drawings are stick
figures and you know the joke here if i
had to explain to a space alien or you
know an English major why this is funny
right that it's a person sitting in
front of the computer but also this this
both contrasts against canoes idea of
programming and also what is actually
done when you develop software wherein
knuth does it talk about you know my
code is crashing when given pre-1970
dates knuth does algorithms this is
software engineer this is programming in
the real world this is only three
nineteen seventy dates is significant
because you know the
getting of the epic was it was in 1970
and so unix times are given starting
1970 but where does knuth talk about
this and also this interaction here the
person telling the joke to the guy this
is funny because we have this culture we
have this funny culture because you know
we like to take things literally but we
also kind of step outside ourselves in
terms of taking things literally we're
very mathematical very analytical but
we're analytical about being analytical
and so we make a lot of jokes like this
that it's both a pun and it's also you
know uses domain knowledge someone who
doesn't know you know about the epic and
also that it's a play on words it's a
pun that you know epic versus epic and
so it's not only that this looks like
just somebody typing on a computer but
it's not there's so much more there and
it's only when you start having to take
these things apart and this is what
signs of Technology studies is really
good at at providing you these lenses
for taking these things apart because
when you to look at the sweep of history
when you look at the sweep of different
cultures for example epic and epic are
only close with an American accent if
you do this with a British accent or an
Australian accent it's not as funny so
so this is where you start to see the
culture and also the the sweep of
history alright so i'm going to show you
saying when recognize this it's the
difference engine this is a built I
think what five years ago Charles
Babbage's Difference Engine often hailed
as you know the first computer I mean
when you get into it there's lots of
debate over what constitutes the first
computer but say a lot of people say
this is the first computer and I'm going
to play you a little video it's I
apologize for the quality of the video
but
I was reading about the Difference
Engine I'd even read william gibson's
book on the difference engine and I said
oh no well big whoop you know it didn't
work he wasn't able to build it was so
big this that and the other thing and it
wasn't until I applied an sts lens and
also that I saw this video that you know
these light bulbs went on and said ah
what are we doing okay so let me try and
find this video see over here
every turn of the engines driving is
carried through years Cavs rods levers
and springs to release an arrest
precisely aligned number wheels the
helical arrangement of steel fingers
continually told the register towers to
find and perform the carrying of tens
and its continuing sweep up already it
is mesmerizing the intricate printing
section can be programmed for one two or
three column a flourish for two font
sizes at once for variable margins in
column gaps even word wrap were
necessary in the spring of 2008 a clone
of de tu commissioned by Nathan Myhrvold
was completed at the Science Museum and
shipped to california at the computer
history museum it would charm new
thousands of discerning eyes today the
crotchety proud genius who never managed
to prove it during his lifetime as a
fair plan to honor as a pioneer in the
history of intelligent machines justices
parlor guests in 1832 suggested
his difference engine continues to
inspire the admiration of his
intellectual heirs a celebrated and
unique icon the chroniclers of computing
Charles Babbage remember never saw it
except in his stubborn pressive dreams
so that's the difference engine it was
built to create calculation tables I
think the closest thing that we have
these days is maybe looking up F values
when you do statistics that you know if
you have ever done statistics as an
undergraduate that you you know
calculate your f value and then you look
up in a table whether it's statistically
significant or not that's the only place
I've ever seen these kinds of
calculation tables used also maybe in
the back back of your trigonometry
textbook you might have a table of sine
and coasts but back in these days
everybody use these values because you
know you didn't have calculators you
didn't have a device that you carry it
around to calculate these things for you
and if you wanted to know them in any
practical usable way you have to look it
up on table and so the production of
these tables was a tedious
time-consuming important problem and
this is the exact problem that that
Babbage was working on okay where's the
software you see the hardware but
where's the software
ah ok so one possible one possible
answer is that there is no software
because the idea of software hadn't been
invented yet but what does it mean to
program this right so the thing with
this is this is a software as we know it
didn't exist here but this device was
programmed and it was programmed using
hardware and it didn't calculate it is
not a this is one of the things that set
this apart from devices that came before
it is that it would calculate an
arbitrary equation I mean within certain
constraints it could only do certain
powers and it could have only have a
certain number of terms and the the
final answer could have at most 30 two
digits but the equation that it
calculated could be entered into it
somehow you would and basically you go
around back and you flip a bunch of
switches and so that's how you
programmed the software or you let you
program the salt I mean program this
device I mean compared to they would
have logarithmic computational devices
that you have a little I machine that
you could crank and then you could say
calculate you know the log is something
calculate the sign of something so you
would have purpose-built devices where
is this one you could change the
equation that you are calculating so in
so where's the software so the software
and the single purpose device more than
the hardware word together I mean it
just it's arbitrary where you draw the
line I mean you can see it these days
what's hardware what software the most
obvious difference now is is your
graphics cards you know what used to be
in software has been put into optimized
hardware for just for calculating pixel
locations so you can have you know
really spiffy graphics is I mean that
the line is shifting right the line
shifts depending on what you build into
the hardware where's the software here
it just depends on where you draw the
line I mean the there it calculates
equations that's fixed that's built into
it what you input as or what you
into this to calculate or what what
equations to calculate is in the back
there's a number of features of this
that is eerily similar to modern systems
132k 32 digits you know why 32 digits
well you could say multiple of two but
he's working with digits I mean and and
you know when we do binary now its base
2 okay why 32 this thing here is the
handle that drives the whole thing you
would have to turn the crank around four
times in order to do one step in the
calculation this is very similar to the
clock in your you know logical
arithmetic unit the thing that you learn
about it out in undergraduate computer
architecture this is the tempo this is
the calculation each step goes around
and around like that I mean it makes you
wonder how much of what we're doing has
been influenced shaped limited
constrained by buyer the history of
computing by the different interventions
that people have come up with okay so
that was the slightest for the video ah
anyone recognize this and yak and yak
aurinia depending on what your accent is
okay can someone point to the computer
this is the computer i have not make her
job title is computer okay they high
during this era and even before it you
know from from in the 1940s 1930s 1920s
they hired young women and it was always
young women to be computers and they
would have their job title is computer
and what did they do while they did math
they derived you know date they did
integrals derivatives and things like
that the calculated numbers very similar
to what the difference engine did like
you know I need you to calculate
ballistics tables I need you to
calculate this or that and and they just
did math all day and then they put it
out these tables and other people would
use them or that I need to calculate you
know some kind of optimization I needed
some kind of you know what is the best
way to do this what's the best way to
you know use these resources so that I
can get the most out of it so that's the
computer she's the computer this they
thought of it as a big I don't know
calculator right it was just a device
and I really like this model here so if
she's the computer who's the programmer
who's programming look who's programming
the ENIAC okay so what does it mean to
program the ENIAC here this guy he's got
the mathematical equations that he wants
to calculate the ENIAC was generally
used for calculating ballistics tables
which are you know how high should I
point the gun and with how much force
should I shoot the the ammunition so
that I can reach a certain place and and
much of large hardware and software
development and this area era was driven
by military requirements either breaking
the code the Enigma code or any
decrypting communications and also for
making ballistics tables so this mote
drove a lot of the software development
and hardware development so he's he's
got some equation that he wants
calculated and she is rigging up the
machine to do the
the calculation that he wants and I I
try to give these this explanation to
people and they said well isn't she just
a compiler and if she is just doing
wrote protein you know wrote allocation
of equations is she really a programmer
or she is this a skilled job there's no
question that this is a skilled job
someone gave them a bunch of these
devices and say you know make it sing
and dance no manuals they had to figure
out how to do all of these things yeah
the baby comes from here or did they
think what did they really think it was
just a calculator thanks calculated it
they the history is ambiguous because
there's the shifting terminology they
weren't quite sure I mean to say that
it's just a computer is kind of belies
our modern mindset all right I think
they I think in modern terms they would
have thought that it was a computer but
their idea of what computer meant is
different from what what we think of
computer time like Adam chains but
having missions
calm you both in you know your tail also
again these kind of computing sweatshops
yeah yeah this is just a question of
degree so but if all is on the scam
yeah which we're getting one more
yeah yeah so what how you actually
programmed the ENIAC was using wires was
using you know hammers wrenches so you
know you each one of these boxes was a
logical unit in that it performed a
particular calculation for example you
know this might be the cubing unit and
this might be the squaring unit this
might be the addition unit and each one
of these things represented one of the
bits in the calculation and so that you
would take the results of the this
computation and then run the wires to
square it and then you would run it back
to run it somewhere else so take the log
of it or something like that so what was
programming moving wires and so this is
a puts a lot of what we're thinking on
its head and yet this is part of our
history this is part of how we think
about programming come back there we go
so many of the first programmers you
know for the front many of the first
computers computers who are originally
women and so for a long time this was a
female dominated field like the almost
all the programmers all of the ENIAC
programmers were women they're the ones
who were the first you know people who
came up with the ways of controlling the
machine to do it arbitrate do arbitrary
tasks just in case you know any ack was
viewed as an accident here's here's a
bunch of pictures that I found on the
history of computing website or the
computing history org website so the
bomb which is based on a Polish machine
used by the British to break codes
during World War two that's a woman in
front of it the Colossus machine a betch
bletchley park again a woman the ENIAC
machine about half women in that picture
the IBM ssec the maniac machine i think
at harvard and then JPL
love this picture 1955 this entire room
then hatton project if you read
fineman's fineman's memoirs he talks
about working with the women there yeah
little series right yeah yeah so here's
the here the explanations for why
culturally one computers at the job
title were originally all women right so
you hired young women with good math
skills to calculate these things what
else computer switchboard our telephone
switchboard operators somebody calls in
you find out where you want to call you
pull out the plug and you plug it in
somewhere else that's awfully like
programming the ENIAC right you take a
wire and then you run it in somewhere
else there's a third factor it just
escapes me at the moment but yeah so
cultural factors like that yeah you
haven't understand why they favor the
women for those jobs where they better
than half were they like or love it
would its culture that these were
acceptable jobs for women yeah so
storable action computer job title start
in civil war essentially they need a lot
of women too
yeah especially if you're sending the
men to go and fight or or if there's
this is also the gender division of work
that the men made the designed the
computers and then or design the devices
and then the women did the programming
Andrew and then you yeah yeah okay so it
also strikes me to slower that picture
just as easily could be a stenography
cooler exactly yeah that was yeah that's
exactly it that was the third reason
that I that escaped me okay punch cards
what does that look like you know typing
sonography and this picture I don't have
a date for it but you can figure it out
maybe from the from the hairstyle and
the clothes this is where it all went
horribly wrong and this is an
advertisement for the computer you know
and here's a user anyone can use it hmm
you know is like you know the suggest
putting a woman next to and saying
anyone can use it and so I in in the
past I've done studies of you know the
participation rates of women and when
the first computer science degrees came
out women's participation rates were
really high you know up in the fifty
sixty percent range especially when they
started out in the math and physics
groups of different universities and it
was viewed as an academic subject and so
if you were good at math this was a
natural transition for you it may and
the numbers kind of peaked in the 80s
and then they've gone down and down and
down ever since that's a separate
discussion that's an entire talk all by
itself but we can think about that all
another thing that may have contributed
to this is that with the creation of
Fortran they so so Fortran when they
after they came up with Fortran they
said ok anybody with who's good at math
can can do the programming now and you
know not anyone who's good at logic it
doesn't just have to be these
specialists and so they serve recruiting
chess players to be computer programmers
and and so that's our to tip the balance
to more towards men because it was the
you know they found more male chess
players so that contributed to it as
well so this is one of the so the point
here is that you know the what is an
appropriate role for someone the culture
of you know what determines someone's
career choice and what the possibilities
that people see for themselves you know
our Sultan socially and historically
determined as well I mean look at all
these historical examples that we just
brought up okay who recognizes this
fortran fortran the first programming
language every single family tree or
genealogy of programming languages
starts with fortran at the beginning
fortran is the parent of every language
that has come since fortran is a high
level language it was created in 1953 by
jim backus na and the it was created in
response to an economic problem not an
intellectual problem it's not that
someone came along and said boy he'd be
cool to have a high level programming
language it's that the cost of
programming computers became so high
that they said we have to find a cheaper
easier way to do this because they would
build these machines millions of dollars
in order to set it up to calculate a
particular equation it would take about
three months to set up all the wires to
have it go just so and then it would run
for a couple of weeks they would get all
the numbers out of they needed they
would print the tables and then we do
the next job computers were becoming
more pervasive everybody wanted one they
could do all sorts of cool things with
it you know you could keep your accounts
you could keep you can calculate
inventory and things like that so in
even but even though people wanted
computers they didn't necessarily have
the computers on site so the computers
IBM was offering as the kind of a
service we would host the computers you
would have a share in the
we weed host this computer for you we'd
have the programmers for you you just
tell us what you want it to do and so
they so when the cost of developing the
software so telling the computer what to
do began to outstrip the cost of the
hardware that's when they say we got to
make this easier so stored programs
programs that were stored in software
whatever software meant because this was
still punch cards punch cards are
physical but this is software so where's
the software okay so they were starting
to see modern lines emerge here so they
would store the cards they would store
the software and in cards and it would
and this is this is readable right you
can read this as a human being and that
was the whole point the and and it's not
just that Fortran was a language Fortran
was also a body of technology including
the compiler that made this possible
Grace Hopper made her name by coming up
with intermediate codes that were more
human readable that you would translate
into computer code and she came up with
these techniques by hand you know when
you see this translate it to this number
again your undergraduate compiler course
this is what you learned Jim Backus came
up with an entire infrastructure for
doing this and also not only did you
translate the codes if you see this turn
right into this code you see this just
turn it into this code some of it was
was was very mechanistic very
algorithmic but part of it was that he
used dumb solutions instead of really
clever human solutions for example the
allocation of which instruction goes
where in memory where you are going to
place these instructions was considered
a real art and this is where where Jim
back has received a lot of his
resistance that you know automatic
programming this is what automatic
programming is not possible you can't
possibly do as good a job as human
beings laying out these instructions in
memory now this is not one of the
criteria for what is the real programmer
these days you know no one is evaluated
on this we've deferred some of these
tasks over to the computer and no one is
any you know less favorably because they
can't line things up in the most
efficient way in memory okay so I'm
going to stop trying to do some history
and try and move into the modern era
okay ah then you want to figure out what
this is it's the output of a makefile
it's a build that's right it's a build
you've built some software you've
compiled it you've linked it and you put
it together into a jar it's a build all
right so what's this it's a build it's a
build all right this is um from the TV
show extreme maker Home Edition extreme
makeover home edition you've got you
know big machines you've got people
you've got somebody standing around
talking to each other other people
working they've got safety equipment and
stuff like that they're making a house
why is this a build and why is this a
build I mean why is it in computer
development or in software development
this is the build but in construction in
the rest of the world this is the build
what are you doing here are you building
the software while yeah you're kind of
building the software a computer is
taking the code that you wrote compiling
it and putting it together well what
about the work of requirements what
about the work of actually creating the
codes what about all of that other work
are you not building the software then
then why is this called the build I mean
there's this is a computer doing all of
the work in if this is what is viewed as
the build yeah maybe there's something a
little bit funny with this picture and
then in the rest of the world this is
the build is it the met
the curve sauce for the
the source code is the blueprint the
source code is the source it's kind of
like in the matrix Oh neo he is one with
the source you know he knows the source
before the building yeah and and
somewhere in this it it breaks down
right i mean the metaphor i think you're
right in the metaphor but the way in
which we think about developing software
i think is these kinds of metaphors
having it made it into software
development kind of makes us thief see
things in a funny way write it this is
kind of like the our use our environment
as users or as customers we're just used
to things being a certain way and until
we kind of say hey what's going on and
this is the then then you can call out
the contradictions and the things that
don't make sense and i think this
metaphor in this analogy is similar to
this it's hard it's a little bit hard to
see but this is a player piano okay and
there's a roll up at the top that is the
music and it can work as a normal piano
as well you can play a player piano by
pressing on the keys but a player piano
what makes it a player piano is that you
put in a roll of music up at the top and
someone is sitting at the at the
keyboard in front of the piano and their
job is to pedal pedal is as you know and
energetically as they can to make sure
the whole thing works and this is a
person playing the piano this is a
player piano this is a piano player so
this person is actually creatively
actively playing the piano this is the
act of creation over there what's going
over on over here this is very similar
to compilation the script has been
written the computer is just doing the
job of turning that script rent from one
representation to another this guy is
like the build master this is
build master this is the build machine
that's the build script and he's
peddling for all he's worth just like
your build master the build masters is
responsible for making the build happen
and this is a bit of a black art to you
know just just actually getting this to
build you know you can't always build
every single piece of software on any
machine I know that from my experience
downloading open source and getting it
to build is you know you need to have a
lot of tricks up your sleeve and I know
many companies have a dedicated build
machine and they have a dedicated person
looking after the build so I think using
the metaphor of the build or using the
label of build for your build process
like your ant script or your make file
or anything like that is like a player
piano and leaving out all of the
creative work other than just turning
your code into zeros and ones you know
kind of elides the work of the piano
player I mean who made who made that
scroll who made the who composed the
music who turned the music and turn the
music into the scroll and also and this
is this I think is the creative work of
computer programming so this is the the
piano player versus the player piano
okay
this is yes yes player piano does get to
control some aspects of the programs yes
patrols me yeah oh wait yes I fascinates
me
they yeah I I think they I think it's if
they don't pedal hard enough then it
goes slower but once you pedal hard
enough then pedaling harder will not
them get the music to play harder or
faster so can you view him as the end
user who runs a program created by the
piano player which is reported compiled
regular application by scroll is the
program and he's then the user like
someone will create the school yeah I
find that metaphor I tried that metaphor
but it's actually if you keep if you you
push that metaphor it becomes really
unpleasant so what are you teaching them
the the end user should do is the under
users entire job to pedal fitting for
the program there this music
but it it separates them from being a
producer versus a consumer I mean is
this the music that they want this is
the music that they're stuck with this
is the music that you thought you wanted
them to hear the scroll to put in there
theoretically theoretically there's
goals it to for whatever it means if
they want to hear I mean I just got to
be playing with a movie like in the
sound of here right and he could be
picking impervious role for the movie
that makes a time
Oh yep firstly you the gentleman on the
top picture more as like an ops team in
a concept you know I work a lot with web
apps the past and teams where we had a
live operation so it was kind of a layer
between the end user and you know even
after code was already built you have
that an Operations team to keep it
maintained and making sure that he only
had a patient who's running properly on
the server so you know I did the user is
like the listener of music in this case
may be able to ask the player to change
and you know but in this case you'd have
a layer of ops that we maintain the code
to work Mitch in bits and everybody can
build anyone else um I think uh I think
none of the what your comments are well
taken i and I think that you raised
possible alternative interpretations of
this distinction but I what I i
intuitively don't like about these
metaphors and maybe this is what i don't
like about software development is that
the user is kind of like a receiver
there's this big gap between you know I
the makers and the people who are
receiving receiving the products of what
is being made and that's a lot of the
what is going on with web two point O
stuff a little bit but that you know the
route the consumers are also producers
that's also where intellectual property
law falls down that you know can I take
use this and make something else with it
or can I create things or you're
supposed to receive this stuff and
you're not supposed to modify it and I
think this conversation or this point
about what is the role of users is going
to carry on in the next few slides so i
encourage you to bring this up again in
a couple yep one of the distinction is
in the lower picture it's not clear
whether she's composing music on the
spot or whether she's playing some music
somebody else composed the moon she's
just playing mm-hmm which i think is an
interesting distinction
I mean sure yeah because I'll about it
in T body washes playing and so so this
is waterfall model I think we all learn
this at school and this is put out as a
software process and this is held up as
a pretty good software process because
this is where I mean even though nobody
uses it this is this is the ideal
because it's clean its engineering that
you do all the requirements you get all
of the requirements and you hand over to
this specification stage what do you
hand over a document and this document
is complete you know and it's specific
and you never have to talk to the users
again and then the specification stage
they take as input a document and where
they output a document and you hand it
over the design phase and this probably
you're getting into a different team
from requirements to design and you hand
over this document and somebody else
makes the design and of course this is
um came from a hardware development
model that you know you make these
things and then there's a manufacturing
step in and is done forever designed to
implementation here you have a little
bit of switch you hand over you know
code as well which is different from the
documents so so we tend to really like
this step this is the part that makes
software programming or computer
programming really special otherwise
we're just writing documents and then
the testing and then the maintenance
we're just handing artifacts over to and
of course we all know this is fiction
right that we hand over there's actually
a lot of interaction there's a lot of
feedback there's a lot of tooling and
throwing you can't come up with a really
good architecture until you've got a
really good requirements and you can't
come up with you don't actually know
what all the requirements are until you
know what's on the design is so it's
kind of like messy and all over the
place and so it's just not as clean as
this and so other process models have
come up like spiral and agile and things
like that that tries
to capture what what are the what the
process should be no okay what's this
that's right very good yes this is a
daily stand-up meeting for an agile team
they're standing in front of their you
know task board and you most of you
probably know but the agile daily
stand-up is at the beginning of each day
you have a meeting where you're standing
up so you try and keep it short under 15
minutes now what did you do yesterday
what are you going to do today what is
there anything blocking you do you need
any help just to touch base with
everyone on the team where's the process
is this software process
oh yeah this is so where is this oh is
it don't even worry about the structure
I mean this is the process by which
software is made right I mean there's
the we did a study couple years ago that
you know we asked people if you use a
process and they know we don't use a
process and when people say we don't use
a process they mean we don't use a
formal documented process but we have
things that we normally do and we have
and we adapt and improvise in the
following ways but I think this is part
of the assumptions of the bias or this
is just how we use the language that if
you don't follow something that's been
written down or if you don't use the
same thing every time you're not
following a process this is the process
this is not the process right is this
the process there's this the process
there are schematic views of the agile
process yeah yeah yeah yeah you you
could show people approximating
the waterfall flowchart or you can show
people approximating the natural flow
guard both of them both of them have
people bb-8
that model
so are you talking about the Delta
between now a model in the execution or
the Delta between the waterfall and I'm
talking about what the textbooks say
process is and i'm talking about that
versus what is the process or what is
the the body of work or the work that
you have to do to get software built
agilent excellence it's not it's not
fair to compare a representation of one
process with the execution of another um
I agree and and I realize I'm missing a
slide so let's pretend i have a
representation of an agile but even if
you do have have an agile representation
and i can i can quickly pull one up i
can i can pull one up because i actually
have one
is that picture the process or those
people the process okay the answer is
yes yes
ok this is the agile process so let's
say is this the agile process this is
the process this is the the prescription
of what you should be doing but this is
the full-bodied enactment of that
process this is the work of developing
the software but I think even my point
is even in this representation there are
things that are missing okay we all
agree that nobody actually does this and
even in this there's stuff that's
missing yeah actually I went to an agile
conference last in in in August and
there's a new process called scrum but
we do scrum but we don't do this we
don't do that and everybody does scrum
but nobody does scrum is called
philosophy that a process that in those
cases maybe act the idea I yo G of
struggle with you ok so this is one of
the things that agile is upfront about
that waterfall is not upfront about
agile you know what is the thing that
holds all agile to get together is the
agile manifesto right and really what
agile all agile processes have in common
is that this belief or the set of values
that you know some things are more
important than others yeah let's start
this man
the art of computer programming
if presumably the implementation of
software development involves quite a
bit more than just bits and machine
instructions
since its built by human there is a
philosophy behind it so what is was
canoes philosophy when it comes to
software development I don't actually
know but I think there's an XKCD comic
about that um I ice I don't remember
reading him any saying anything specific
about this but judging from his actions
he would say it's fairly mathematical
and it's about you know the the input
creation of codes and things like that I
mean look at look at la check for
example right he created la tech because
he wanted to have something to typeset
you know his his documents because when
you went from version one diversion to
his system had gone away and this is
what he created for people to create
documents it looks like code right
that's my guess and okay so there the
point I'm trying to make is that this is
even if this is the process not this
right even if you say let's do a jalur
stuff that's missing from here and we've
been doing field studies of agile this
is not one of the teams we study but
we've been setting agile teams and agile
artifacts and with the roles that agile
artifacts play and let's see let me let
me skip this one because we're running
out of time a little bit okay so this is
the diagram that we came up with for the
you know for lack of a better word the
process how is it that people interact
with each other what are the roles that
artifacts play in the environment how do
things work together so that we can
develop software so each of these you
know actors are participants in an agile
software project and they interact they
have their input into the process
through a user story either you're
feeding in user stories or you're taking
a user story and you're implementing it
you also have personal artifacts this is
something that we found comment
all tea all the sites that we study that
everyone hides their personal artifacts
oh I just wrote these notes for myself
agile says you know as little
documentation is you know no no
unnecessary documentation and that
official documentation is lightweight
right so there's nothing so people hide
their artifacts and say oh this is just
for me and that's why we have these
personal artifacts and it's like the
more you hang around a team the more
these things they can't as a researcher
they tried to hide them from you and so
they have their own personal artifacts
and what is being built it's not just
code is being built but test cases are
being built functionality is being built
so the software in use is being built
the that's the deployed running
integrated software and then there's
this whole thing has a piece of
conversation about it because very
little is written down how do you get
requirements you talk to somebody how do
you do validation you talk to somebody
how do you figure the dependencies you
talk to somebody so there's this entire
conversation that's going on in a new
and this is kind of like these are
individual private spaces and this is
the public space in a project and these
these people come from their private
spaces or private representations of
work and participate in this public
representation of work and they do this
through user stories and they're able to
do this but because they are backed up
by their roles backed up by the personal
artifacts personal credibility
background and experience and things
like that so that what we found in this
study made us wonder about what is what
is the process of building software and
it reminded me of the Brooks quotation
from the from the last slide that what
is building software you know Andy
Brooks said I believe that this is Fred
Brooks from no silver bullet I believe
the hard part of building software to be
this
vacation design and testing of this
conceptual construct not the labor of
representing it in testing the fidelity
of the representation and so the views
of software process that we see
described and you know in this in this
model or even in this model places
source code at the center but leaves
everything else out of it like source
code is it this is what we are making
and so when you interrupt somebody to
ask a question they feel like you're
interrupting their work or that if they
have to go to a meeting to figure out
what the requirements are they feel like
this is not really my job you're
preventing me from coding which is what
I really want to do I see wrinkled faces
so that means it's time to stop and have
people ask questions yep so I strongly
agree with your final conclusion that is
much more to software development than
just the coding but I think I disagree
yep semantically with what you're
defining as hardware software and
algorithms and programming so I think I
would define for example software as
well the hardware is the physical pieces
with where the software is more the
changes in the algorithm and there might
be an input which is
which doesn't affect the algorithm but
that affects the performance of the
thing so for example in the difference
engine i would say that there is
programming but all the programming was
of the hardware and there to my
knowledge there is no change in the
algorithm you can do on the fly without
changing Hardware but there are inputs
that people can do too and then I think
for the like the ENIAC for the running
of wires I would distinguish there's
someone who comes up with the what wire
should go where to do the algorithm that
we wanted to compute and then there's
somebody who actually plugs in the the
wires and i'm not sure if they were the
same person thinkers okay and so then I
I would say the person coming up with
the algorithm is the programmer and then
again as my definition I'm not sure how
well that issues with yours or others
but the programmer is the person who
comes up with the algorithm and then
there's someone else who might be the
same person who puts it into action in
the wires or anything's up it could be
in person my my nine-year-old last night
wrote a web browser by reading from a
book and typing exactly what it said now
I would not call him a programmer yet
but he created a program but I think the
person who designed the program in the
book was the programmer and so my son
I'm just sort of typed in the things and
so I'm defined a programmer as a subset
of what's needed the person who can sort
of take what's needed the the
requirements and turned it into code
that's what knuth writes about and
certainly is an important part of the
process but I agree that there's much
more to the processes that we gathering
requirements and the architecture and
figuring okay does anyone else want to
jump in okay well I I know you all want
to jump in i can tell what okay so um
the thing that I think is missing from
that diagram is sort of a shared
understanding of the three people in
that diagram of what they're building
which is I mean the artifact is one
manifestation of what they think they're
building but they themselves in their
heads have some sort of shared
understanding with when they go to the
scrum meeting and the daily stand-up and
they say like oh I'm working on this the
other couple people in the room also
have an idea of what why are you working
on this and how is it contributing to
the overall effort and what is the
effort and what is the goal that's kind
of missing I think um conversation that
you have to do
but and
I would argue there is no such thing to
share interesting we all have mental
models we don't have a shared one but we
we synchronize them through the
conversation so I think what's missing
is your XKCD people with the big empty
heads those heads are full of stuff and
they're constantly being sent through
conversations and through exam
through creating artifact both personal
and share
I think what's credibly from from this
and the picture of agile or the picture
of water problem is that they're humans
that for example if you go back to the
picture of agile there's a sealed
cardboard box of the opens the box and
takes that piece of software out and
appropriates that software for their own
needs there's I deliberately left that
out I I didn't know I i deliberately
left that out because that is a huge
complicated yet there is it's as
complexes what we talked about in that
one hour today I could spend another
hour on it and and when I bring that up
it actually confuses the conversation
about this but I'm happy to give another
one hour talk and I'll just say I like
to comment me about was the years who
Charlie said yeah my brother code I
don't 30 but
so that I like to comment about that and
it reminded me also like the projects
are working on I folk who are aware of
oku but for you know for children
programming the xbox there's so many
different ways things are changing now
and code and I guess for me the way that
I view it is more and more now with
waspy you or or something that's a bit
higher level than just the actual
process of writing the code in fact the
way I look at it is every step of my
life it's kind of like you know if I'm a
programmer but without the developer in
a little effect every step of what I do
and I think it doesn't matter what
everybody covered or whether I'm doing
something else if they're only
extensions of what the core motivation I
have to get the job done I think writing
codes only just another way of doing it
just like you can say different
languages you can say the same thing
kind of yeah no I agree with that um and
I mean I started off this talk by saying
we have intuitive ideas about what is
real programming what's not real
programming whether someone is technical
or not technical and I haven't made up
my mind on a lot of these issues and the
thing about sts is that it's good for
raising questions but it doesn't give
you any answers right so I've raised a
lot of questions about what counts as
programming what constitutes programming
you know and I'm pointing to the parts
that miss that that are missing or that
might be missing or hear our assumptions
or here's how we use terminology in a
certain way and and and and that was my
goal I'm not quite sure what I'm going
to do with this but that's the that's
the goal that you know I've raised some
interesting questions that I can tell by
the looks on your faces that some gears
are turning in your head and I think I'm
just going to finish off with one last
XKCD comic which is exactly your point
back there that you know who is being
programmed is it the computer that's
being programmed or is it us as
programmers who are being programmed and
as you're saying when when I'm walking
down the street I can see myself as a
programmer and this is what i love about
XKCD is that you know what is it me as a
programmer and
there's a there's an entire ethos about
this I can look at the world and
sometimes I laugh because I've been
reading all this sts stuff and I can you
know the the the joke and SK CD is that
you know you kind of step outside
yourself and your analytical about
yourself but then i'm reading this sts
stuff and is this this part that's
watching the analytical part and going
oh yes i just saw you behave as a
programmer and it is like impossible
that the SPS reading that i've been
doing is just gets into everything and I
see things going on in the news or I see
things going on I know in politics or
somebody's comment I said I know why
they said that it's because of this that
or the other thing but yeah this is the
compiler speaking up to the human saying
you know double check your pointers so
who's being programmed and this is you
know what Gina talks about so who's
being programmed what are we programming
people to do we've created the software
and we've you say oh while social
networking we've got facebook and saying
that this is the box that social
interactions happen in is this all of it
is this the sum total I mean I'm not
sure I'm not comfortable with face
saying that Facebook is it and I'm not
comfortable with ever saying that you
know all of human interrelations can be
captured by software and yet software
tries or at least you know for the
purposes of banking or for the purposes
of walking up to an ATM you know I'm
being trained this is what I'm allowed
to do in front of an ATM anyways there
there ends my talk